dieser mann sorgt dafür dass stricken
und gestricktes immer beliebter werden
steven west gebürtiger us-amerikaner 32
jahre alt seine farbenfrohen
strickmuster begeistern vor allem
jüngere und männer die designs und
muster stammen alle von mir ich entwerfe
und strecke jedes muster und schreibe
die anleitung da steckt viel
leidenschaft drin und ich mag es
wirklich sehr was ich mache
besonders gerne arbeite ich mit ganz
vielen farben farbe inspiriert mich am
meisten
auf instagram hat der in amsterdam
lebende strikt designer rund 225.000
follower in seinen online tutorials
zeigt er wie man seine bunten
geometrischen muster selbst stricken
kann humor und unterhaltung spielen in
seinen clubs eine wichtige rolle
ich möchte noch viele weitere lustige
video tutorials drehen so dass ganz
viele menschen lust aufs stricken
bekommen und die videos müssen auch
nicht immer so technisch seien sie
können auch spielerisch und modisch sein
seine muster entwirft der gelernte
tänzer und choreograf zunächst als
skizze dann übernehmen er und sein team
die ausarbeitung mittlerweile wenig
steven west kultstatus und hat fans auf
der ganzen welt regelmäßig
veröffentlicht der bücher mit seinen
strickanleitungen er hat eine eigene
wohl marke gegründet und ist mitinhaber
eines wollgeschäft in amsterdam
ich halte mich nicht gerne an die regeln
und strecke auch nicht nach den regeln
ich war nie auf einer design schule oder
so und habe mir das alles sehr
spielerisch aufgebaut
der 13 jährige berliner constantin
siebeck zählt zu den fans von steven
west das stricken hat ihm seine oma
beigebracht ideen und anregungen findet
er online bei level 3
das soziale netzwerk hat sich auf hand
arbeiten spezialisiert und weltweit rund
neun millionen mitglieder mit stricken
machen
auch der 39 jährige fabian fiedler aus
berlin hat das stricken für sich
entdeckt
der pianist der eine musikschule
betreibt hat schon rund 100 werke selbst
gestrickt darunter pullover schals
mützen socken und deppen
stricken ist für mich eine pure
leidenschaft und ich stricke wahnsinnig
gerne weil ich dann mich abends nach dem
langen arbeitstag einfach aufs sofa
setzen kann machen wir den kaminen und
genießt diesen moment der ruhe und kann
mein fokus auf eine sache legen und
alles andere drumherum vergessen und
ausschalten aber nicht nur selbst
gemachtes liegt im trend
in den aktuellen modekollektionen der
herren ist strikt in allen variationen
zu finden
ob bunt gemustert oversize oder ganz
schlicht an strickmode kommt man in
dieser saison nicht vorbei
das kann auch sascha utrecht bestätigen
der berliner führt seit vielen jahren
ein wollgeschäft aber nicht nur das er
organisiert regelmäßig strikt reisen und
strickt events wie zum beispiel strikt
kreuzfahrten auf grund der pandemie
finden seine veranstaltungen derzeit nur
digital statt wie sein wöchentliches
online strikt meeting
[Musik]
anfangs hatte ich dann facebook live
shows gemacht konnte aber nur einseitig
agieren mit den kunden
und dann dachte ich da gibt es auch noch
zoom und andere plattformen aber
aufsuchen habe ich dann halt wirklich
gemerkt aber ich kann interagieren ich
kann mit den leuten sprechen sie ich
kann sie was fragen sie können mir
antworten
ich kann den was zeigen wir können was
entwickeln weil wir können einfach nur
spaß haben und und schnacken dabei
zurück nach amsterdam zu steven west
sein geschäft im herzen der
niederländischen hauptstadt ist bereits
etabliert und an kreativen ideen für die
zukunft mangelt es ihm nicht
ich könnte mir eine eigene talkshow im
fernsehen vorstellen mit vielen
tanzeinlagen
wir könnten neue techniken lernen und
ein paar tutorials zeigen
ich könnte alle meine freunde
interviewen das wäre verrückt ich weiß
nicht ob die welt dafür bereit ist
stricken eine erfolgreiche masche die
auf dem weg ist auch eine männersache zu
werden
[Musik]